I noticed that doctors instead of
treating the patient they would treat
the problem that is a huge
problem naturopathic medicine utilizes
the ability for nature and the
environment to support our overall
health the basics that our ancestors
would have used when you go down that
route amazing things happen interesting
there's a fine line between benefit and
problem you should only feel better when
you detox you should not feel worse if
you feel worse it's a red flag if people
have been exposed to something what are
detoxes you could pretty much recommend
people try folks this is extremely
important
okay Dr Ben Lynch welcome to my podcast
awesome to be here Michaela I was just
commenting on your glosses I like them I
feel like I could use some what are they
for yes we could all use them if we're
staring at screens you could use them uh
they are shielding blue light that
affects our vision and blue light is so
bad because it's a it's basically an
oxidant it damages our eyes and so here
we are so conscientious about taking
antioxidants and vitamin C and vitamin E
and glutathion and all these other
things but our eyes are really really
susceptible to this type of damage so
you know we wear sunglasses outside so
why don't we wear blue blockers when
we're inside on
screens is is blue light from screens
I'm I told you I'm not knowledgeable in
this area but is it not similar somewhat
similar to the sunlight you're getting
anyway during the day isn't it okay
during the
day that's a good question um I'm not an
expert on Blue Light either um I would
say that the if there is blue light
coming from the sun which there might be
um I would say that the this light
coming off a screen would be highly more
concentrated in it ah so and a funny
story about these glasses is I was I
walked into my son's room in the evening
because I put these on in the evenings I
have redder ones in my bedroom for
actually in the bathroom when I get
ready for bed I put the red ones on
because it filters more blue light and
if you put them on during the day right
now it'll make you too sleepy so I walk
into my son's room in the evening and
he's getting ready for bed he's like Dad
what do you think of my new uh star
night sky like what are you talking
about yeah and he goes I just plugged in
Star night sky what don't be stupid dad
just what do you think is that cool
Galaxy I was like dude I don't see it I
was like oh wait a minute I go like this
I like oh yeah that is cool I put my
Blue Block go and he's like whoa let me
see so then I take my glue locks off and
he couldn't look through and he's like
oh my God so those star night
constellations in our kids' rooms no
good for for uh blue light but they are
pretty cool looking and he was pretty
impressed that I couldn't see a thing
with from the blue light blockers
Scarlet wanted to get one of those star
night things and I said no like you can
have something red if you want that kind
of shows up in your room but you can't
have blue stuff yeah yeah so before we
get started can you give a brief
background about who you are and what it
is you
do yeah so um I have a guy that lives in
Seattle uh married to a lovely woman for
23 plus years three boys uh I own a
company called seeking health and
seeking health is a supplement company
that we're transitioning to a health
company Where We Are trying to be
more providing more tools more
educational uh information about how you
can support your own health um that's
been going on since about 2011 uh I got
my Bachelor of Science from University
of Washington and so molecular biology
and then I was Premed and I was when I
was Premed I was like well I don't
really like any of the type of doctor I
don't want to be a surgeon I don't want
to be a neurologist I don't want to be a
dermatologist I don't I don't want to be
a family doctor nothing interested me
and so it was actually kind of
frustrating um so I I pulled myself out
of school and my junior year travel
South Pacific and Southeast Asia and
while on that trip I got really ill in
India shocker and while I was really ill
in India uh a local said let me let me
just take you to our local doctor I'm
like oh God here we go um so I was
introduced to ayurvedic medicine and
ivetic medicine is an ancient east
Indian style of medicine and uh I got
significantly better about 80% better in
about an hour or less and medicine I
actually used is still the remnants
right there on my shelf as a
momento um and then it led me to
studying naturopathic medicine which I
fell in love with because naturopathic
medicine utilizes the ability for nature
and the environment mindset lifestyle
food uh nutrition to support uh or
overall health and we can utilize minor
surgery and and pharmacology when we
need to but our primary driver is you
know the environment the basics that our
ancestors would have used with uh
targeted nutritional support which has
been my uh Forte I fell in love with
biochemistry in junior year of high
school and I just you know when you find
one of those things you absolutely love
it just kind of Falls in your lap and
you just want to keep it there your
whole life and biochemistry for me was
that I loved how it
connected science and
biology with our immediate lives and how
our body functions utilizing these
nutrients that we either consume or
don't consume and the chemicals which we
all consume and we don't want to and how
that interferes with our biochemistry so
when you when you go down that route
amazing things happen and uh you know my
goal is to help educate the masses about
their own
biochemistry in a way that is practical
and
actionable um and provides tremendous
success and it it's it's been helping a
lot of people so
far hey everyone speaking of detoxing in
this episode I've been saing pretty
consistently to help detoxify since I
became ill again from mold while living
in Florida seriously that stuff is
everywhere and it's something to look
into if you weird symptoms like insomnia
and food sensitivities low blood
pressure heart palpitations it can cause
so many things and it's so hard to avoid
it's very frustrating and it really does
impact you mold anyway back to the sauna
the benefits to my energy and mood have
been super beneficial and I've been
using saunas for years because of it
when I'm traveling I use Bond charges
infrared sauna blanket I also use it at
home which works just like a normal
sauna by helping you sweat as well as
burn calories helps reduce inflammation
stabilize your mood and deal with other
symptoms like brain fog and anxiety by
helping your body detox so anyone who's
interested in detoxing or this very
health focused podcast episode needs to
try saing along with other ways of
detoxing but Asuna is key Bond charge is
also super easy to set up and has free
shipping easy returns and exchanges the
reviews are amazing go to bond
charge.com
slmp that's b n CH H rge.com slmp and
use code MP to save 15% off the link is
in the comments below enjoy the rest of
this
episode I I think my audience is
familiar with this but so I was like
I've been chronically ill just forever
and I've got things under control right
now but like they're barely under
control all the time so I'm doing well
but if anything sets it off it's just a
Cascade of hell and I always disregarded
natural paths I think because my mom was
very was a very hippie person and very
open to to everything and a lot of the
things she was open to turns out that
they were real but my dad was very
logical and mainstream Medical Science
oriented and I kind of took after him
and was like oh naturopathy you know
they're talking about leaky gut what is
that this was years and years and years
ago and just disregarded it for a long
time partly because I was so entrenched
in the medical system that the doctors I
was talking to also disregarded it and I
trusted them so it took a while to to
switch around but uh obviously I've
switched around I I wanted to talk to
you specifically for more selfish
purposes because I've been on this lion
diet for it's been 5 and a half years
and I've done a ton of reading on gut
healing leaky gut and and and that's you
know what I have and my assumption going
into the diet was I'd go into the diet
for a period of time maybe 6 months calm
everything everything down heal a bit
and start reintroducing things and that
that would go well and that hasn't
happened to me so I've been on this diet
and I've been managing it and I'm very
grateful for the diet because I was very
ill before it but I haven't been able to
reduce the inflammatory responses and in
the last couple years I found out the
hard way that my environment was playing
a much larger role in my health than I
had originally thought so I always had
air purifiers I was using non-toxic
products I was really careful with what
I was putting on my body and what I was
around but there were some so mold is
what got me in the last couple years uh
that I couldn't see it was in drywall
and I got sicker and sicker and sicker
and so recently I've been doing more
research into like how to detox these
issues and stop the histamine
intolerance and um various inflammatory
responses that my body seems inclined to
do so I wanted to start this podcast off
with I know you basically specialize in
in what histamine and forces and what to
do about it so that we could start there
and then just work our way up from
there yeah definitely
um and before we do that you know when
you said that you were in a family
surrounded with logic and and utilizing
logical uh methods and approaches
towards obtaining
Health totally understandable I mean
that's what I want to do as well which
is why I love B chemistry biochemistry
is extremely logical and granted uh
biochemistry is a human term that we
made up um it could have been called
squiggles you know for that matter but
it's it's uh so we utilize this aspect
of science to direct our understanding
of how the body functions becomes
dysfunctional and how to restore the
function okay so in in a logical
sequence of events and understanding how
the body does that and it's called
mechanisms of action and then we have
physiology and pathophysiology the the
the methods in which pathology or
disease uh becomes into our systems so
basically medical school is the first
two years is learning how the body works
the next two years is how does it get
broken and then the rest of your life as
a health professional it's how do you
fix it which is why they call it a
medical practice uh because it's
extremely complicated and so when I was
working with patients
um I I noticed that doctors they would
see a a individual come in and that
individual is labeled with something
like say histamine intolerance or mold
exposure and they would treat them the
same instead of treating the patient
they would treat the problem and that is
a huge problem and I I quickly learned
that let's say a PA came in with um
heavy metal toxicity and that was a huge
one that I worked on CU I I I worked
heavily on environmental medicine shift
so my specialty in naturo medicine is
actually environmental medicine cool um
and I actually got to work with some of
the top doctors in the world uh on with
environmental medicine and and uh that
individual uh uh wrote the sequence of
books
uh chemical sensitivity behind me um
that's cool God his his name is escaping
me
um my gosh I got to find his
name Ray that's it Dr Bill Ray I don't
know if you've studied his work or not
but William Ray is phenomenal um he's
since uh passed um but so let's say a
patient came in with heavy metal
toxicity we would treat him the same and
they some would do really really well
some would have no benefit and some
would get worse and I was like Well
there must be genetics involved here
this was early early 2000s so you know
20 some years ago when genetics wasn't
really utilized in in medicine and so
then I started looking at why these
patients got
worse and we would give them a lot of
sulfur compounds for moving Mercury out
of their body okay and if you give it a
lot of mercury compounds that can turn
into sulfites and if youat a lot of meat
that can also that's a lot can be a lot
of sulfur as well cruciferous vegetables
can really flare people um and so anyway
I I I suggested why don't we use a
mineral mum so hard to say um but mum is
a is a mineral that's naturally found on
our planet in foods that processes
sulfites so if you have sulfites
intolerance you get headaches
irritability red rashes hot and um
headaches asthma difficulty breathing
and so these in individuals who we were
giving these massive amounts of sulfur
compounds supplements um like glutathion
nyine glycine what have you on
dmsa um they would get these rashes and
I say well let's give them linum and I
don't know the percentage of improvement
but um a significant amount of patients
who we started giving mum to didn't have
the reactions anymore they
stopped and um so and my supervising
doctor said oh yeah they just get red
rashes and and flush and they get
headaches that's just a detox yeah so I
you know it's and and I also want to say
before we head into the histamine
intolerance um thing genetics is a is a
huge aspect of what I do because I
really like focusing on the individual
not the
label so the label of histamine
intolerance or mass Cell Activation
disorder that's a thing you are Michaela
okay so we need to focus on Michaela not
his
intolerance and conventional medicine
and conventional doctors and even
naturopathic doctors and integrative
doctors and functional medicine doctors
they are they they get set in this realm
of logic of icd10 codes the patient
walks in with a thing and they treat
that thing instead of the patient and
then stuff just goes it just you just
don't approve and I had patient after
patient that I worked on and um their
charts would be you know few inches
thick it be chart number four
and I I looked at their the summary
they're struggling with fibromyalgia
their whole for the whole 10 years and
so when they came in to see me I just
pushed their charts away I said let's
start over let's start over and um I I
you not and in in one visit I
identified the potential problem and um
they did a lot of cleanup but granted
they set the stage for me it's like
someone's you know unscrewing the cap on
the bottle they loosened it right and
then I got the cap off um but in in one
visit I identified a huge problem my my
treatment was stop all your
supplementation jump in a
sauna come back and see
me and she could not get up her first
time I saw her I I went in the in the
lobby to go get her she goes excuse me
it's going to take me about 10 minutes
to get up from a seated position she was
that sore she had to move her arms
slowly
and then she used that other arm to pick
up her other arm and then just get up I
mean she was so sore she could barely
move um and uh and then the next time I
saw her in the lobby it was like a month
later and I was all excited and and my
supervising doctor says yeah he because
I I don't know why I let you stop all
those cleansing supplements and fasting
supplements and detox supplements and
parasite killing supplements but you
know we'll just see what happens and and
cuz I was really pushing for it I walked
out in the lobby she jumped up literally
ran to me and gave me a huge hug a yeah
so that that was really cool um so
utilize supplements wisely um yeah and
and treat the individual not the the
thing so you're you wanted me to discuss
histamine intolerance I I do focus in
histamine a lot um but histamine is a
histamine is is associated with
essentially everything and I I don't
want to give histamine a bad name
histamine is extremely important to our
to our physiology histamine supports our
ability to think and focus right now our
histamine levels are ideally at a
certain amount that allows us to listen
to this conversation and learn and stay
awake if youve ever picked up an
anti-histamine on the back of an
antihistamine said this this drug may
cause drowsiness so low histamine causes
drowsiness the inability to learn pay
attention stay awake Etc um and
histamine in the in the right amounts
also supports our immune systems
response to a trigger either it's mold
or um you know bacterial or viral
infection and so that histamine that
comes from that response amplifies our
immune system to go deal with the the
problem the issue is some
individuals if if I say
fire in in my body
uh the response is oh okay there's a
fire let's go put it out and some people
they're like you know basically
infection happens like for my wife for
example and it's not fire it's fire oh
my God fire and her body just over
amplifies and it just stays nuts and
keeps screaming keeps yelling attacks
everything her joints her brain um her
soft tissues um and it just keeps doing
it and the fire is gone I mean you you
wipe those those those bacterial and
viral infections out you know you've
been sick for months now but uh you know
you've been you've been fighting
yourself um so you know I was looking at
your genetics and um you I just emailed
you your histamine report that it we
working on right it's still in testing
and what's interesting in your histamine
report is you don't have that many
susceptibilities genetically yeah to
reacting to anything histamine
specifically related yeah so then you
get that report back and you're like
damn I swore there was something
genetically triggering my responses to
things and there are I mean there's
there's some things in here um that I'm
looking at now that uh genetic
variations that are are increasing your
susceptibility to have higher levels of
histamine but then you have other things
that uh reduce your
susceptibility so how do you interpret
that right it becomes difficult so then
that's where you go into your lifestyle
and your diet and all that um and I I
want to say too from a logical
perspective what is a gene you know we
hear the term gene or genetics and we
think all those are difficult I'm going
to freeze I'm not going to pay attention
to this interview because I don't know
anything about genetics well genetics is
pretty simple uh genetics is a study of
of how genes function in our body and
what do they do so a gene
has a specific job to do and sometimes
you do multiple jobs so ju today
prepared us for this interview right he
set up the the the infrastructure the
podcast me setting up this other app for
for the interview prior to getting on
now we've got you know other programs
running in the background so you can say
you know one was a gene to get this
podcast going now we have another Gene
that's recording it there's another Gene
you know the microphone so they all have
these function funs and so I could have
uh I could place this cap on my podcast
mic or cover it with my hand and even
though the podcast microphone is plugged
in with all these wires it's connected
to all the systems I could block it with
my hand let's say an environmental
chemical or let's call it mold and
you're not going to hear me anymore
right or it's very muffled doesn't sound
good so you have to remove these
obstacles so the genes can function and
perform their jobs so and if you have a
genetic variation you can you
can you inherit these things that alter
how your genes perform and they're not
necessarily bad because natural
selection relies on genetic variation uh
and and allows us to adapt in our
environments the problem is our
environment changes so quickly um
because of our you know race of of
technology that our genetic um genetics
AR aren't made up for I mean where are
you originally from your ancestors you
know uh yeah like almost like 95%
northern Europe like Irish UK little bit
of
Scandinavian Germany water Germany yeah
so let's let's think about that in terms
of weather conditions light conditions
Sun conditions foods that are eaten in
those areas
clothing um you know let's go back 200
years right let's think about 200 years
ago what happened in Scandinavia in
Germany in those those times and you're
probably you know hunter gatherers
fishing um you know in the in the winter
it gets pretty damn dark and cold and
where you living now
Scottdale I just moved though right from
I was in Miami and that's where I got
ridiculously sick from mold and I was
like I'm going to the desert that's it
yeah I'm really happy that that you
moved when you said Scottdale I was
actually relieved so good for you very
yay okay that's that's fun very smart um
but you know think about your you you
moved your ancestral genes to
Miami right where uh they're like where
the hell are we right now and then you
you move now to Scottdale you know and
I'm not saying we need to go all go back
to where where our ancestral genes came
from you don't need to race back to
Germany or or
Scandinavia um but it's it's always
interesting to
think about that because that's where
your genes are designed to survive and
thrive because your ancestors survived
and thrived there and 200 200 years is
far enough to go back you don't have to
go back to like caveman times you like
maybe I should live in a cave but a non-
moldy cave yeah uh I I'm not sure that's
a very good question um I I don't know
but you know if we we just think about
200 years ago you know technology the
advancement of technology and years has
been pretty ridiculous yes um so you
know we didn't have any of this and we
were still eating food that was food it
wasn't packaged by three major mea
corporations that were controlling
everything and you know 95% of the
grocery store you shouldn't even touch
um you know I love paulino's videos
where he just walks around and bashes a
lot of stuff um so including vegetables
which is interesting and uh I use Paul's
work all the time when my wife says you
need to have a salad I'm like no I
really want to
S so I love my meat um so anyway uh get
me back on track here yeah okay so so
jeans so I did when I was first when I
first it when I it finally occurred to
me that I wasn't getting better in the
medical system I kind of went in a bunch
of different directions I did 23 and me
I tried to plug the raw data into third
party services to see if there was
anything weird about it I did my
grandparents I did my parents on both
sides I was like maybe there's some
weird pattern somewhere that I can find
that's contributing to these
inflammatory responses I didn't really
find anything there was no you're unable
to detoxify this or you have problems
with this like there wasn't any huge red
flags that I was kind of expecting um is
it possible that you can be put into an
environment and you can turn on
genes oh 100% I mean just think about it
this way um in my book dirty jeans I I
talk about about this okay when you lay
down in a a dark room your your genes
are your melatonin genes are turning on
in darkness they're turning on in order
to start releasing melatonin that's why
these are so that's why blue blockers
are so effective in the evening because
blue light inhibits the release of
melatonin or it does something along the
the Melatonin um things I I forget
exactly what the mechanism is but anyway
to UPS your melatonin and um so light
turns on genes that support some things
and light also turns off other
genes okay so food will do the same
thing certain foods will turn on some
genes and some foods will turn off
others and when I say turn off turn off
is a harsh statement it might slow it
down so there it might turn off some
genes or it might just re really really
um slow them down significantly or it
might slow them down um in their ability
to perform just a little bit okay it it
depends so grapefruit when you eat or
drink grapefruit um like grapefruit
juice you are slowing down a very very
important detoxification Gene called
cytochrome p450 um there's multiple
cytochrome p450s there's many many many
genetic variations that occur with these
they're really important for processing
medications uh environmental chem
chemicals and then it processes these
these compounds into actually usually
more reactive compounds that you now you
need Phase 2 detoxification to come
through like glutathione to help get
them out of your your system so it can
be beneficial to have a a a slower
cytochrome B 450 but grapefruit will
slow that down remember that that lady
who could barely get up when I told her
to jump in a a hot taona well I didn't
know her genetics at the time but when I
looked at the the supplements that she
was getting
they were pushing the phase one
detoxification really really hard folks
this is extremely important okay so if
if if you are detoxing you know once a
year or twice a year and you always have
these detox reactions you should only
feel better when you detox you should
not feel worse you feel worse if you
feel worse it's a red
flag and and don't don't just settle for
oh it's just a die off reaction or
detoxing no no no no you should only
feel better so when you walk into your
house you start cleaning your house or W
taking a shower you start washing the
mud off your knees if you're in the yard
you should only get cleaner shouldn't
get dirtier right so um it's the same
thing so uh I heard you resonate with
that so if if you are supplementing with
phase one types of nutrients and some
are phase one and two so when I say that
phase one means it transforms a compound
like Mercury um uh and or uh Tylenol is
another big one um it'll transform these
Tylenol or mercury into a more reactive
compound less so I don't think Tylenol
is reactive and I could be wrong here
but I don't think Tylenol is that bad
until it hits your cyto corn p450 genes
or enzymes processes into a more
reactive compound and then that's where
it can wreak
havoc so and now you need the phase two
to help clean up that mess and then
phase two leads to phase three where you
pee it out or poop it out or sweat it
out so I looked at her supplements they
were mostly phase one hardly any phase
two I don't recall if she was
constipated or not probably because it's
taking so many s she was taking so many
so if you're constipated you're just
reabsorbing all these compounds yeah um
and not getting him out so I said okay
let's stop all this phase one pushing
which were her supplements and this was
my argument to the doctor let's get you
in phase three support where you know I
want to recommend colonic and enemas and
and all that I I actually don't remember
um where she was with that so we just
threw her in a sauna and uh yeah
thankfully it worked so when you started
detoxing with health professionals or
yourself did you notice that you got
incrementally better for a while then
got worse or walk walk us through that
yeah so it was mostly back in 2016 2017
when I was I thought I had some sort of
bacterial infection or viral infection
that was just keeping my immune system
in an inflammatory State I hadn't
considered mold at that point and I
tried a bunch of things I I sprouted a
uh sodium metabisulfite allergy like
true allergy so did my dad which we'd
never noticed before very severe so like
anaphylactic reaction to sodium
metabisulfite did some research found
malinam the reactions were so severe
that I didn't even feel any different
with malinam so that that was kind of a
neutral thing but I tried a bunch of
kind of detox protocols it wasn't
through a health professional it was
just trying certain supplements and I
felt worse on everything I tried I tried
a bunch of different probiotics I tried
the low histamine
probiotics um I think my gut was too
damaged to tolerate probiotics maybe um
activated
charcoal was either neutral or maybe
slightly positive um recently from the
mold exposure I've been taking
colestyramine which I don't I know if
that's how you pronounce it I've been
calling it
CSM that's so that's been the only thing
I think I've ever taken that helped and
it helped dramatically it was crazy
actually I had um so just so so people
know it's a binder it's not systemically
absorbed and it binds bile and then when
you poop it out I apparently it just
takes whatever is in your bile and
releases it I don't know if they
actually have evidence of what comes out
but um it just made me feel better but
while like I was having while it was
traveling through my digestion I could
feel it and I'd get symptoms so I'd like
sweat and things um and feel worse but
it was interesting because I knew that
was right before I was basically going
to have a bowel movement and that lasted
for about a month um and I got like some
pain say say that say that bit again
about B bowel movement so right before I
was going to have a bowel movement my
symptoms would flare a little bit so I'd
get nerves nerve pain and sweating um
almost like a reexposure that's what it
felt like uh and then I'd have a bowel
movement and it would be gone but every
time I took the Cs this was while you're
taking the kocy or before while so this
was after I started that lasted for
about a month and then since then
everything's been good but that's been
the only detox like helper thing I've
tried that hasn't gone terribly wrong
like usually I I just feel I feel so
much worse and I trying to reintroduce
probiotics I had some medical help there
and the entire time it was like oh
you're just getting through a die- off
period you're just it's just a bit of a
her reaction type of thing and it was so
bad that I was like there's I don't know
this doesn't feel like it's an
improvement this feels like I'm reacting
to it and it didn't go away so that's
why I you know gravitated towards the
diet because I just cut out everything
wasn't taking any supplements I was like
just like trying to survive um and that
lowered a lot of my symptoms so it just
when you said you know if you're taking
supplements and you're experiencing all
these bad reactions but it's like die
off and you're detoxing I didn't feel
like that was right either mhm that's
good it's it's that's awesome that
uh a lot of us ignore the symptoms that
our body is presenting us yeah you know
if if someone knocks on our door or
rings a doorbell or or we get a
notification on our phone we respond to
that but why don't we respond with when
we get a headache and think okay I have
a headache what did I do to get this
headache
what happened oh I you know I did have
another drink last night and I ate a lot
and actually went to bed really late and
my cell phone was on next to my bed all
night so yeah that kind of makes sense
why I get a headache and and my water
intake was pretty low a lot of us just
will swallow an aspirin or a Tylenol and
just you know tell our body to shut up
and and you don't want to do that you
really want to listen to these symptoms
because it's our body's way to say hey
there's some dis function going on take
a pause for just a few seconds
backtrack what what did you do because
you did something and if you didn't and
and and that doesn't mean that it's
blaming it's it's evaluation so
logically go through your past events
and say okay I did this I did this I did
this what was new that's always a very
good question what was new and also what
has been recurring is also a very good
question so recurr while something like
cholamine for you could be really really
good right now it might at some point
yeah not
be and and you have to be prepared for
that because whatever may be
lifechanging for you right
now your body is is adapting and
changing and maybe hopefully improving
so you don't need that cholestyramine
anymore and at some point that
cholestyramine is going to be binding
various uh nutrients like full8 and b12
and now you possibly can get full8 and
b12 deficient
which it can lead to other
problems so um and have you ever heard
the term secondary bile acids no okay so
you familiar with bile yes okay so can
we talk about your genetics publicly
yeah yeah okay so I've been going
through your genetics your your strategy
report that you ran and then the
histamine report that you ran and I've
been scouring it looking for certain
things and um you do have genetic
susceptibility like me to have reduced
bile acid
synthesis so and uh so there's a a gene
that really supports um well the
production of of bile and it can if you
have these genetic variations your risk
for fatty liver increases tremendously
and your risk for gall stones and gallb
issues uh uh increase significantly and
from that also so is sibo sibo is stands
for small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth have you ever had symptoms of
sibo or issues with sibo yeah when I
first went on the diet I I mean I'd
taken a lot of antibiotics throughout my
life um I got a C defil infection um
which was brutal which I got under
control with
fmt thank goodness um but yeah I looked
into sibo uh fecal matter transplants oh
okay yeah do you ever use my BL ey no I
didn't try that because my react I kind
of put probiotics all in one category
and I tried a few of them and they were
so horrifying that was like H I don't
want to it's scary probiotics can be
very very very very problematic as you
found out um and uh and it's because
probiotics while they're really tiny
tiny bacteria they they produce
compounds and when you're taking
billions of them they produce a lot of
those special compounds so they can
produce serotonin they can and serotonin
is associated with gut motility meaning
how fast the stool moves through your
digestive system if you're constipated
taking serotonin producing probiotics
fantastic if you have loose stools and
you take serotone producing bacteria oh
my God you're you're not doing well if
you have high histamine and you're
taking lactobacillus vulgus or
lactobacillus helveticus or fermentum um
you're going to be hating life you your
strep tock same thing um but sacris bori
is actually a beneficial yeast it's not
a bacteria and everybody freaks out
about the term of yeast but sacr myard
is so well researched for C diff and uh
so any time people are taking another
Pearl here folks anytime you are taking
antibiotics you should always go to the
store or online and from a reputable
company by sacy
Berardi and uh you can just put that in
phone to have series spell it for you um
but you take sacris po while you're
taking your course of antibiotics
because antibiotics again are
antibacterial they're not anti- yeast
and so the Acres stays in your gut and
it helps protect your gut while you're
taking the bacteria and you're you're
not your likelihood of getting C if
reduces dramatically oh that's not very
very protective that's cool yeah you
wouldn't think about taking a yeast to
count
medication that kills everything but
east that's right right um and then
antibiotics
themselves um there's some back there's
some antibiotics that are really really
harmful on the system um floral
quinolones yes uh very very harmful did
you ever take any floro quinolones no uh
my dad when he was going through benzo
aspine withdrawal and being allergic to
everything like a bubble person like me
um coid he got coid and I couldn't visit
him in the hospital because they Banned
Me from visiting and I went to visit him
and he was
in terrible shape and I was like what
did you give him a Flor Quinn alone like
I I know that for people who have
neurological issues as well it can be
even more toxic so no from what I know I
haven't taken any dad got hit really
hard with one but we stopped it right
away those I avoid everybody in my
family
avoids good yeah make sure that your
note if if if doctor asks you do you
have any um susceptibility medications
or or what have you you can you got to
you got to glorify these
things to make it sound like if you take
them you're going to die yeah so then
they actually put it in a chart and they
notate it and they make damn sure nobody
gives it to you because otherwise
they're just going to say oh yeah I
don't like Floric quinon they're just
going to they're not even to put it in
your chart yeah and they'll give it to
you so Flor quinolones I mean unless you
absolutely have to as as as your life
there's probably still some other
alternative out there um than Floric
quinolones because they are they've
they've wrecked people too many too many
people called flocks right yes exactly
flocks and um so you can say well which
bacter which antibiotics are associated
with Floric Quon again Ask Seri which
back which antibiotics are associate
with Floric quinon and just say you have
a massive allergic reaction to anything
in foro quinone family um and uh stay
away from those um but going back to my
point of secondary bile acids so bile is
a compound that is produced by your
liver um in order to help you uh digest
fat and absorb fats and the nutrients
that are found um within that also
supports B12 and vitamin D and Insulin
um It's associated with so many things
all sorts of different hormones um so by
is very very
important and um so your liver produces
it and then after it produces it it's
store it goes through these little pipes
it lands in your gallbladder your
gallbladder holds the bile and then when
fat comes by your your small intestine
from food um you know let's say you're
keto and you're pounding the fat and um
you know you're going to be releasing a
lot more bile into your small intestine
to absorb that fat from the ketogenic
diet um or or if you're eating a a
really fatty piece of meat um you know
riye staks are really good especially
that the Outer Perimeter where where it
uh you know got a little more fat on
there now you be squirting some bile the
problem is a lot of people don't squirt
bile because it's too thick bile should
be two parts of a compound called phosl
choline and one part cholesterol most
gall stones and the most reason people
get their gallbladders removed is
because of the high amounts of
cholesterol found in their gallbladder
so you get the these cholesterol based
stones and that is because their
their uh liver is not able to push the
cholesterol out so they get fatty liver
they get gallbladder problems um they
get gall stones they get intolerance to
Fat they get right shoulder tightness um
they can't fall asleep at night they
have uh intermittent um diarrhea
alternating with constipation um they
get super itchy um irritable um so on
and so on and so I I've I've been
talking about Gall but a lot um lately
on on my Instagram and people have been
really resonating with it because I've
been talking about a lot of symptoms
with that now let's say you don't have
any of those symptoms but you secrete
the the bile into your small
intestine and there's bacteria I forget
which ones they are but there's there's
certain bacteria that will transform
that bile acid into a secondary B acid
and secondary B acids are really toxic
they make you feel like crap
so when you mention that you're taking
the col ayamine to bind bile and you
feel so much better it's been
transformative for you um you know you
still have a long ways to go but coling
has been that thing to help you that
tells me okay you've done the fecal
medical transplant but there's still
something that is you know transferring
that bile acid into a converting that
bile acid into a secondary B acid which
also makes sense because you are very
susceptible to not feeling good from
probiotics and some probiotics will make
that uh secondary B acid worse um as
well oh what are the symptoms what are
the symptoms of feeling worse are they
like is there no Ray or are there some
specific patterns yeah that's that's um
I would say fatigue is a big one okay um
muscle
soreness um headachy just like you feel
poisoned yeah okay okay you just you
just feel poisoned you feel toxic you
feel heavy um have you ever been to a
restaurant or you've done something in
your life where after you've done it
maybe even right away or or after a few
days or a week or a month you just feel
light and your energy is good and your
mood is good that's where we need to be
all the time but unfortunately health is
a moving Target it's very very Dynamic
um so we need to we need to try that but
bile acids they just make you feel
lethargic headachy irritable
um the the
Chinese uh Med medical doctors back in
the day I don't know if they still do or
not but they they they call it black
bile uh black bile is associated with
anger
irritability um inability to sleep heat
rising yangong um deficient Yin uh all
these different types of statements so
uh keep doing that colestyramine but my
thought is what's what's increasing that
uh secondary bile acid and you also have
a genetic variation which reduces your
ability to synthesize that phosph
choline remember you get gall stones If
the ratio of phosy choline is less than
2: one and so many people are say oh I'm
high cholesterol I don't even eat that
much meat I don't eat much fat I don't
eat eggs uh why is my cholesterol so
high I don't eat carbs this doesn't make
sense well there's there's genes out
there that uh support your body's
utilization of cholesterol to make
hormones and also support its transport
so again this is extremely logical stuff
because if you understand how the Body
Works how it gets messed up and what the
function of certain genes do you can
really um align these things in a
logical sequence and logical Manner and
see how the body is supposed to work and
then again like I demonstrated by
covering the microphone which I won't do
again but uh you know something is is
messing up your bile acids um but you
have a gene that's associated with with
reduced production of fosy choline and
that's called pemt and pemt is is uh
very very commonly uh slow genetically
especially in women and there's genetic
variations that can slow it upwards of
70% so that means you're only have a 30%
capacity of that Gene functioning and in
women when your estrogen levels drop
let's say you become
postmenopausal at some point and if you
are
postmenopausal um then your estrogen
levels drop and low estrogen levels um
are also making it harder for your
ability to make phospholine because
estrogen promotes the synthesis the
production of uh phosy choline and
phosphaline if I don't know if you ever
taken that supplement it's very slippery
it's extremely slippery you get on your
fingers you just can't get it off it's
like castor oil almost and so you know
you're your liver gets just loaded with
phosy choline and um that just helps the
the cholesterol slip right out so then
you don't get cholesterol based gall
stones anymore so if youve had your gall
stone
removed the the problem of the gall
stone has been removed but the horrible
thick bile has not been resolved and you
still struggling with that so your
symptoms are still there they're just
different than your immediate pain in
your gallbladder because that's been now
removed but now you still have fatty
liver you still have uh reduced bile
acid is and bile acid flow and um you
know right shoulder tightness and
itchiness and what have you and here's
an interesting study that they did on
mice is they they they took mice poor
mice and they uh they tied a suture in
the bile duct of the mouse so the bile
couldn't get out and these these mice
had no digestive issues so you said you
you had sibo at some point well I had a
cifal infection so and it was in my
small intestine so yeah yes I guess okay
yeah yeah that that's definitely an
infection yeah um so they they tied the
bile duct of these mice so the bile
couldn't get through into the small
intestine they got
sibo they had bacterial overgrowth in
their small intestine and and the and
the researcher like oh that's really
interesting
so they didn't treat the mice with an
iotics they removed the the suture of
the bile duct which allowed the bile to
flow back into the small intestine what
do you think happened they got rid of
the sibo exactly sio went away oh well I
mean that makes sense that's interesting
yeah so you know everybody has been
taking refaim or all you
know prescribed antibiotic after
prescribed antibiotic they might get
some relief for a week or two um or not
um or and some people may even been
lucky and they've they've gotten
complete relief um but if you just if
the doctor's saying all you just need to
keep cycle refax and maybe you're on it
all the time or low dose you just stay
on it um nobody's talking about the
gallbladder issues even the leading
Experts of sibo are not talking about
the gallblader and the bile production
and the bile flow dropping into the
small intestine because bile is a
natural
antimicrobial so it supports insulin
secretion and diabetes it supports your
hormones your thyroid your bone health
it's is so so incredible supports your
Healthy floor and your gall and your
your small intestine um so supporting
gallblader health is incredibly
important and some things that you can
do with that is I wanted to ask you
about so you're you're eating meat now
right yep for the last five and a half
years okay um how fatty is this meat and
if have you noticed think back so if
you've had a a very fatty cut of meat
compared to a more lean type of meat
like bison or Buffalo or venison um or
elk um how do you tend to
feel um after so when I first started
the diet I was kind of averse to fat and
then about 8 months in I craved it for
about 2 years like lots of it I was I
was eating a crazy amount of fat and
about 2 and 1 half and my digestion
wasn't good
but I felt like it was making me feel
better
cognitively and then about two and a
half years in I think around that uh I
switched over to lamb that helped my
digestion a lot so I think it was
histamine intolerance from the aged
steak I was eating and then about 3
years in I switched over to leaner Cuts
because for whatever reason just how I
felt the fat wasn't doing it for me
anymore and the leaner so I eat I eat
mostly New York's now I can eat beef
again um so the hist intolerance seems
to to
be I don't know somewhat dampened to
when I was living in the moldy house it
was really bad then um so I would say
I'm not super super high fat but New
York's are pretty
fatty okay and how well do you chew your
food um probably not well I kind of
inhale it and then continue
working okay and do you work while
you're
eating um not for dinner but generally
yeah okay don't look at me like that no
no no
I I do it too um so I wrote the book
dirty jeans not perfect genes right so
uh and it's the the cool thing is when
we have uh when we dirty our own genes
for the lifestyle uh that we do at times
um the key is to knowing how to clean it
up so you you could take digestive
enzymes or or something um to help
support your digestion um so you ever
heard of the calic phase of digestion uh
yes but I don't know what it is yeah
calic phase of digestion is the initial
phase of digestion it's when you're in
the kitchen cooking it's when you're
preparing your food it's the
anticipation of food it's smelling
touching preparing uh visually seeing it
that's all the spyic phase that is
preparing your body to get the digestive
systems going because it it sees the
anticipation of food do you have a dog
or a
cat I've had a dog can't can't tolerate
anything now but I used to have one yeah
so what would happen when you walk
towards the pantry what happened and you
picked up that bag of food or you know
that you prepared something you got
their bowl what did they do start
drooling basically exactly right so
spyic phase in an animal pretty instant
in us as well so I'm going to say the
word
lemon sour extremely sour and lemon
what's happening in your mouth right now
anything yeah probably salvation yeah
yeah right is that that crazy just by
saying the word lemon you're
anticipation of having a lemon come to
your mouth has already made you increase
salvation right so 40% of your digestion
40 40% of your digestion is a
anticipation of eating
food so it's extremely important that we
we I don't want to say respect but we
utilize the calic phase of of our
digestion more often than not and
there's times where we can't and um you
know or just don't want to um but notice
that okay how's my digestion after and
if you're inhaling the food you're just
going to feel heavier you're not going
to feel
lighter um so I think it was a Japanese
who said uh chew your water drink your
food so something along like that
meaning chew the hell out of your food
and uh or if if if you think about your
stomach your stomach is just a bag full
of acid and it should have acid but the
acid isn't there until the spalc phase
tells it to produce more acid I mean
it's there but it's in lower amounts the
pH will actually drop with the spalc
phase um otherwise we probably burn our
tissues more um
so but the acid if you think about it if
if you swallow a piece this big you're
only getting the acid around the outside
of that chunk of meat right so you're
only digesting the perimeter of that
meat not the interior so that comes
through and that little piece this piece
might you know fall down to
maybe a half of the size so half of this
bite of food is now just being pooped
out because you didn't properly chew it
so if you chew this piece um you know
this a little bit you know in a lot
smaller pieces now that acid can get
around every little tiny bit of your
meat and the food that you eat and so
can the protein based enzymes and the
carbohydrate based enzymes they can just
go around all around the little pieces
of food and process it break it down so
you can absorb it and get the nutrients
that you really really need so I would
love to see you um honor the sehic
and honor yourself and and dedicating
time to your eating and and to yourself
and also chewing the hell out of your
food and cutting it into smaller pieces
and literally putting your fork and
knives down on the table and leaning
back and and eat something pretty um you
know stare uh Scottdale is beautiful
there's lots of stuff to look at or
engaging conversation a good
conversation with your husband not not
uh no arguing that that will shut it
right down um but these are again you
know here I am focusing on genetics and
looking for genetic variations but at
the same time I will flip right back up
to the very very basic
fundamentals right so we've we've talked
about how you have a genetic variation
that reduces your ability to synthesize
fosti choline um you know significantly
but we've also gone right to the
fundamentals if you're coaching a
basketball team or a soccer team and you
don't coach the fundamentals of of
passing the ball but you focus so
heavily on you know some type of trick
you know you're GNA lose the game so um
you got to practice the fundamentals and
Implement yeah um does okay two
questions one does throwing a steak in
an air fryer and flipping it count as
preparation that's the first question I
suppose absolutely yeah because you've
gone to the fridge right yeah you you
remove the the steak you're preparing
the steak you season the steak or maybe
you haven't seasoned the steak um and um
you know no that that is all preparation
for sure um there's um have you looked
at the auto Grill Auto Grill yeah I I
just Swank same kind of thing though
okay the the I don't like using gas um
as propane powered I but you know
I I have not know noticed any issues
from that um it's very clean burning um
you know I remember growing up with my
with my dad when he would get the
charcoal briquettes and spray the
lighter fluid all over it and light it
and that's you know that's pretty
bad um but no I I would say that that is
definitely um a good spalc face so
you're you're doing that now we just
need to reduce your workload while
you're eating and uh um you know just
try you one meal and maybe work a
different meal um but give it a shot
it's it's really really
important okay I'm I'm convinced I do
eat in really small bites so at least
that helps that's that's great that's
kind of an
automatic thing so my mouth isn't open
when I'm eating yeah okay well now chew
it yeah got it and chew it really well
um and you will also notice that when
you chew your Foods really really well
uh you eat less because you become
Fuller faster because uh you're
absorbing the nutrients faster and your
body has these amazing senses of
feedback mechanisms what have you and
it's like oh the satiety signals will
will fire so if some people are
listening right now and and they're
they're always hungry and uh there's a
kid at our house uh that he's a he's a
teenager and he just inhales his food
the kid's always hungry he's just eating
all the time I was like we got to chew
your food man and um he's just a skinny
rail um he goes I don't get it I like
well chew your food chew your food Che
food and and it's funny my youngest Theo
he he'll look at me sometimes and we
have a rule of no phones at the table
and and um there was one time where I I
came to the table either with my phone
or with a book or something and and he's
sitting there with me and he's like Dad
I'm like thank
you yeah so you created a monster
yeah no he he I I'll say Theo back to
him sometimes too so we all We All Fall
backwards speaking of supplements you
may or may not know that I have launched
a hangover supplement called
Afterparty right here which you can get
at Fuller health.com linked Below in the
comments no drinking isn't non-toxic or
healthy however it can be fun especially
if you don't abuse it ruin your life
with it Afterparty works by breaking
down a seal to hide which is responsible
for poisoning you after drinking the
main highd do ingredient di hydr myin is
backed by peer-reviewed studies linked
on my website Fuller health.com to help
reduce alcohol damage I really can't
describe how much these help there's a
30-day money back guarantee so you can
try them with no strings attached go to
Fuller health.com code MP for 15% off
linked in the comments enjoy the rest of
this
episode I've got a lot of people
interested now that I've been about mold
cuz like it made me so sick interested
in like what I'm doing a detox and how
that's going and everything um what
what's your opinion so I I'm working
with a practitioner who's diagnosed me
with cers which is this chronic
inflammatory response syndrome and I was
like well I definitely have sort of some
sort of chronic inflammatory response
syndrome so that's fair um I don't know
how it's going to go because I haven't
tried it and I'm pretty skeptical of
everything all I know is the
colestyramine has helped and and
removing myself from that environment
has obviously helped um how do you feel
about some practitioners focus on mold
as an issue for inflammatory diseases do
you think there's Merit behind that for
sure yeah I do um the problem is when
you go to a specialist in a particular
thing they're going to focus on that
specialty they're going to ignore some
of the things like yeah chewing your
food um so so just be mindful that
you're seeing a specialist
and what their specialty is go there for
that but don't forget about everything
else that's going around right so I'm
looking at your your genetic results
here on your histamine pathway and you
do have um increased susceptibilities
for inflammatory responses
so the the question is um you know to
what degree to what extent are these
genes contributing to that to and to
what extent is the mold and potentially
these secondary bile acids that are
happening and there's got I I suspect
there's still something going on in your
your small intestine large intestine
stomach me too yeah but
like I mean I assume so but I don't know
what to do about it I don't know how to
find out what the problem is yeah and um
there's there's a a a very good friend
of mine and colleague uh she's an
Australian naturopath Elizabeth lamber
um I'll put you in touch with her and um
she's been doing quite a bit of research
on polyphenols and the guts and bile
acids and have you ever tried
berberine yeah I tried berberine but
this was when I I mean I was so sick I
tried I tried berberine it didn't make
me feel good but I also felt quite bad
but I mean yeah like I told you I've
been loathed to introduce supplements
because even introducing certain
vitamins if it's not injected right they
you know I get insomnia and feel awful
they're pretty severe reaction so it's
like ah forget it maybe supplements
aren't for me right so you're you're
when you take a supplement you know
these bacteria or Yeast or parasites or
whatever is in there
um are are feeding off of those
nutrients and then they're producing
more compounds and more secondary pile
acids and you feel worse which is why
you
can't yeah so yeah you're you're feeding
the monster literally um and you do have
uh and and
so I will preface that yes we ran your
histamine report we looked at it um I
don't see anything um just jumping out
at me like there's no genetic variation
that says oh my God this is this is the
one right that's usually that's usually
not the case but I will I will also say
that when we look at gen genetic results
or when we look at people's genetics we
don't look
for high risk
risk um and and very rare genetic
variations we look for common genetic
variations that affect
individuals um modly moderately or
significantly but we don't look at the
really rare severe ones um because
frankly they're really rare and if
they're that severe you're going to
notice it pretty quickly at Birth um but
you do have an HLA
dqb1 Gene um which is a significant find
then you have some uh inflammatory cyto
kindes which are also more sensitive so
when your body yells fire they jump and
they they're screaming and yelling at
each other to you know over prepare but
interestingly this this actually may be
a a more significant thing is is
um infection fighting so there's there's
a gene called myop peroxidase which
actually makes a compound that is found
as the main ingredient of bleach so your
body actually makes its own
bleach and you have a
um uh reduced ability to produce your
own bleach yeah and it says um you might
have react you might have lower I'm
reading now you have lower incidence of
many diseases triggered by reactive oxy
species and inflammation but you're more
susceptible to disease is triggered by
things like H
pylori helicobactor pylori lives in your
stomach so if if if you think about it
if you have a Gene's job again think
about it as as a logical way the gene
myopro proas mouthful is to produce
bleach and you have a reduced ability to
make Bleach then the hpylori is going to
be like sweet I'm going to reside down
here and if your calic phase of
digestion isn't very strong your ab your
ability to
synthesize uh more stomach acid is also
reduced and I was talking to an expert
in H pylori and he says for every decade
in life that we are is basically the
percent likelihood that you have hpylori
so your dad's risk for hpylori is
significantly higher than
yours right now it's that common just
due to his age yeah it's extremely
common yeah okay um another one um is
nox um nox is a is a gene is also um uh
it's NPH oxidase its job is to produce
prooxidants oxidative stress to fight
infections and you have a homozygous
variant which is reducing your ability
30% according to research papers so you
have a 30% reduced ability to produce
reactive oxygen species needy needed to
fight infection from pathogenic bacteria
or fungi the variance lower expression
can be prot protective for
cardiovascular and other inflammatory
diseases yet exhibits reduced
Effectiveness against fighting pathogens
which might be one of the reasons why
you have to be on this chamine so
persistently which explains why you
can't take supplements which explains
why you know you you have to take IVs
for nutrients not yeah swallowing them
right so
again you and I this is the first time
we've we've talked we've chatted on VI
DMS for years um and uh but this is the
first time we've actually had this
conversation in detail so I don't I I'm
just throwing out suggestions right I'm
not I'm not saying this is the thing but
looking at your genetics and talking
about some of the lifestyle things that
we found out like you know the
phase of digestion and so on and now
these genc
variations um you know it's it's pretty
pretty useful stuff to to know your your
genes um where the susceptibilities are
and it's also interesting that um you do
well with eating meat because when you
eat meat you have reduced need for some
of these enzymes that are really slow
like you have a 70% slower Gene it's
mthfd1 in your folet
pathway that's really low but if you're
eating meat it's not really as
significant
anymore interesting yeah so um and and
chfar is similar you can you could you
know uh liver if do you eat liver or
organ Meats not really I tried to
incorporate liver in and it honestly
didn't make me feel very good which I
didn't know why it was like digestive
partially and
then so like maybe once a year cuz I'll
get a craving sometimes but like no not
really I'm really just eating red meat
okay
um uh have you had Paul saladino on your
your podcast yet like years ago we're
gonna have another podcast though soon
okay yeah I think you should because
he's come a long way um in his
understanding and I I would have Paul on
and I would chat about these things um
because I don't know what organ meats
are more tolerated by our digestion
which ones are easier to digest than
others um be pretty easy you would say
you'd think that yeah I don't know
what's wrong with my body you'd think
it'd be easy yeah but I um I was having
dinner with him once with him Mike mutel
and and uh they gave me this uh quarter
inch by or like half inch by half inch
cube of Frozen liver it wasn't cooked it
was just frozen and they they they cut
it and sliced it and they froze it and
like this little silicone freezer tray
that you use for you know food prep um I
was like oh guy all right went in Rome
here we go and um I ate it and it it
actually the cold was
refreshing um I can't stand liver by the
way yeah I can't stand liver um it's
it's tough It's gross it's just this
weird texture um and uh but that Frozen
morsel that I got um was pretty
impressive um it tasted just fine it was
refreshing and I got an immediate uh
Buzz from it and a good Buzz not like a
Red Bull Buzz um but I don't think I
could tell you what a Red Bull Buzz
feels like CU I don't think I've ever
had it um it's not great but uh yeah I'm
hesitating a little bit to recommend raw
organs and meat to you given that
there's I think something in your
digestive system that shouldn't be there
this has been my assumption for a very
long time was there's something there
but I don't know how to figure it out I
don't know what it is fecal matter
transplants haven't mattered I can't
take probiotics so I can't fight them
that way and I can't eat foods that
potentially fight them
because the response is just like
crippes me um so I've just been like
maybe it'll go away and then I lived in
a moldy house and everything got worse
so then I was like maybe I have immune
dysfunction from years of mold cuz
there's black mold in my house as a kid
too uh which is when I got quite sick
so yeah that's where I'm at okay I I
uh I'm going to go in in in doctor mode
a few questions here um when did you
last feel
good I mean like really good I I felt so
I feel pretty good right now now but I
would like when I feel really good I'm
like high as a kite feeling good and so
I probably feel like I'm at 70% right
now but 50% is so awful that 70% feels
very good I felt really good in 2018
when it was about 6 months into the diet
I moved into a new apartment no no let's
let's go let's go earlier than that oh
my gosh I I haven't felt good ever
before
2018 like I don't
remember so as a young girl no I was so
sick I had I had arthritis almost all
over my body I was chronically fatigued
I was anxious I was itchy all the time I
couldn't breathe through my nose like I
didn't breathe through my nose till I
was like 23 when I changed my diet so
it's just
forever yeah were you breastfed
C-section no breastfed yes okay
C-section breastfed was it a complicated
pregnancy
um apparently I was in fetal distress
when my mom was giving birth which is
why they did a C-section I don't know if
that was true or not but not that
complicated the pregnancy wasn't
complicated okay um have you ever done
genetic testing looking for a gene
called uh
fut2
no okay I would go through your reports
the problem with genetic reports
is that you have humans preparing these
genetic reports and some of
these organizations that are preparing
genetic reports don't know what the hell
they're doing they're just copying other
genetic reports trying to make a buck
yep and and they they're giving you
information that is actually leading you
down the
wrong route so I say that
uh because there's there's a lot of
reports out there um so be careful
there's some reports I think that are
are quite good um but fut2 is is a
genetic variation that's that
um is really important for mucosal
protection against bacterial infections
and also healing and and um I'm I'm
going to butcher it so I'm going to type
it in real quick here
um my original like hypothesis was so
when I was about six months old I got
really sick with strap
and um I was put on antibiotics and I
ended up with a very severe yeast
infection after the
antibiotics and then after that like at
by the age of two I had arthritis
everywhere so I was like maybe there's
some sort of strep but that'd be Al so I
don't know hopefully it's not viral but
if it's bacterial I was thinking strep
seems to be what started all this mess
unless there was something that made me
predisposed to the strep infection in
the first
place okay have you been treated for
yeast systemically like taking nice
Statin or anything no I had um I had
Candi overgrowth tested by stool tests
but when I went on the meat diet those
tested negative after about 6 months so
I never took anything for
it okay okay um so yeah nice Staten is a
is a quite saafe uh medication that is
very targeted for yeast um which is
uh as you said you're possibly it's it's
gone um testing though is also
inherently problematic you would think
that getting a lab test uh would be
bulletproof in terms of evidence and
accuracy the problem is it's it's
riddled with issues um so that's why I
like what I call empirical uh testing
where you do some action and you you
await the result and you you identify
what that result is is that result
nothing okay is a result something right
was a positive or negative and how
much um and and did that also trigger
other things that are bad or other
things that were good it's it's pretty
much that simple so if I take a a
glutathione
lozenge then I feel Clarity in my head
starting within about 5
seconds then after about a minute um my
vision is is is brighter and my head
becomes even clearer and then about 5 to
10 minutes later I have an increase in
uh happy mood and more energy I feel
lighter like overall so you it's just
like these incremental improvements and
that's what I want you doing when you're
changing and applying different things
you know when you're eating say if you
eat rabbit how do you feel if you eat
bison how do you feel if you eat fish
how do you feel um fish I probably
wouldn't recommend um I tried because of
histamine yeah oh histamine yeah that's
how I like how I got to the meat diet
was taking extensive notes about what
happens when I do X was awful because
usually when I did X which was
reintroducing a food it' take three
weeks to recover it was like very slow
process until I was just like okay
everything's out let's just start again
at zero but then I haven't been able to
get past zero so I'm okay like I'm okay
now the mold really did me
in yeah mold is mold is terrible
terrible and let's hit that for a second
but I I really want you to um research
the fut2 G it's a secretor or
nonsecretor if you are genetically a
nonsecretor then your ability to fight
infections in your nose in your mouth um
digestive system is is reduced
significantly so now you're more prone
to infections and then there's a
compound out there a supplement which I
tested for a long
time not very well but I it's because I
also didn't look for people but I also
read the research no that's not right I
I
read Facebook groups in the fut
um boards on Facebook talking about this
supplement called 2fl it's two
apostrophe capital F capital L it's like
some crazy weird word of course um so
there's tfl and then there's a
l nmt or something like this it's a it's
another um oligosaccharide that is
commonly found in breast milk so you
naturally get 2fl
high levels in breast milk if your
mother is a
secretor oh your mom has to have the
fut2 genan be as a secretor if she's a
nonsecretor you're also not getting it
cool okay so this is a really important
Gene to know about so one question I had
written down actually so say people are
trying to they've got damaged guts or
something's going on how effective is
either breast milk or raw milk
in maybe overcoming pathogens in the gut
like can you just start again kind of
yeah yeah so um I've been working really
hard trying to formulate a a gut
supplement and it's very hard it's very
difficult because everybody's different
I can't just Target Celiac or Crohn's or
Aller ofius or what have you because
everybody will react to different things
based upon their microbiome and other
things I will say that I do know in the
autism spectrum realm that a lot of
parents find a lot of success from camel
milk yeah I've heard that yeah right so
interesting yeah cam milk is extremely
expensive because camels half they their
gestation period I think is longer and
they also have to have all their milk
for their young for the most part they
can the the camel ranchers can only take
a little bit per per pregnancy or not
pregnancy but per time the the baby is
is feeding um so it's not like cattle
that just Mass produce it probably with
hormones as well yeah um so I I don't do
dairy from cows yeah um I'm goat I do
goat very very well I do goat cheese
well I do goat milk really well goat
yogurt I do so so but my gallbladder is
similar to yours I can't tolerate fat
very well um and the first thing that I
notice with fat intolerance is not a
altered digestion that's next um but
it's it's heaviness underneath my right
rib cage because that's where my liver
and Gall batter is and yours too and
everybody else is um and if you if you
grab your fingertips and um you kind of
lean back and you you kind of dig like
underneath this this area right here so
here's here's my ribs and you just put
your fingers and you hook them
underneath how does that feel does that
feel okay or a little achy do you say
left side or right side right
side try to relax your stomach and and
just try to curl underneath that lowest
rib I mean it's kind of uncomfortable
but I feel like yeah it's probably more
uncomfortable than the other side yeah
so if you go underneath your left side
you know I don't really I'm tight over
there but I don't feel any discomfort at
all yeah interesting it is more yeah
there's more on that side oo that's
scary yeah so there's a um so I'll just
I'll I'll change this before I I I go on
another tangent but camel milk would be
my recommendation for if you're looking
for a a a milk that is closest to human
milk camel milk is it I think goat milk
is second cow milk is pretty far away
from looking like human milk in terms of
the
proteins um so that is why Cham milk is
so well tolerated because it's very
close to breast milk cool okay and do
you not drink Dairy have you tried the
I've avoided Dairy forever cuz it made
my arthritis so bad and it was one of
the worst foods I could eat but I never
tried you know the A2 raw milk that
everyone's talking about and I have not
well um I still don't tolerate A2 okay I
still don't tolerate raw either oh um I
I don't tolerate raw milk I don't
tolerate soap oh I'll be more accurate I
don't tolerate raw cow milk I don't
tolerate A2 cow milk um and what I
notice is um I get a slight headache and
I get a an earache in my right ear um
and then I it gets a fluid in my right
ear it just it feels like I got water in
there and it pops Wiggles um moves
around so that that is uh that's what
happens to me when I drink Cow Dairy of
any type cheese milk yogurt um doesn't
matter from from cows I'm going to let
you be the tester there I'm just going
to avoid that but I drank it when I was
a kid I drank a gallon a day of cow milk
when I was a kid no problems I ate wheat
as a kid no problems well H let me say I
had I had a ton of Hine problems as a
kid so maybe it was a problem but I
didn't have the the symptoms that I
associate with gluten or calir that I
like I do now um and there was times
where when I went to Russia my wife is
Russian and so when he went to
Russia um I could eat
their uh wheat no problem and I ate the
I drank the cow dairy products no
problem and we got it in this big glass
jar um from the farmers over there and I
I had no issues with that either what
how did does that make I hear that all
the time from people going to Italy
being like I'm gluten intolerant here
but in Italy I'm not or I can drink
Dairy there how does that make sense at
all if it's not the type of cow it's
like the hormon industrialized farming
what yeah industrialized farming
techniques here in the US are pretty
pretty damning on our health um so I I
would say that's probably the the
biggest thing and plus we use we utilize
chemicals and compounds and processes
that Europe bands yeah right if I don't
know if you ever seen food babes posts
on Instagram yeah where she will compare
the ingredients of Skittles or Fray or
Doritos in Europe compared to us and
granted they're still crap but they're
cleaner crap in Europe than they are
here um so but let me let me get to your
your gallbladder again um they actually
massage your organs organ massage that
sounds horrifying
yeah it does um but it's
extremely uh effective so did it
help uh yes big time and immediately
what yeah Dr Aaron Choy uh is the guy
who did it for me but basically what he
did is um he really compressed me from
uh front and back and uh had me lean
over and he came from behind me and he
was working on my my gallbladder and
liver and he he actually got his
fingertips all on the tip of my
gallbladder um and you can too if you if
you know how to do it but you just you
have to relax and you you dig down if
you you know look at Google images and
you can see where your gallbladder is in
association with your your ribs um but
if it's extremely tender don't do it um
and uh um but yeah so he did it with me
and a little bit TMI I had an amazing
bowel movement after amazing um thank
God not during and um but what it was
interesting after he he compressed uh me
from you know front to back like this he
he was pushing really hard he's a pretty
strong
guy so he really compressed my side and
he held me like that so imagine your
liver it's you know it's it's full of
fluids and bloods and whatever else and
he compressed it and he kept it
compressed for a little while and he
maybe he compressed it maybe let's say
25% and then he let go slowly really
slowly he didn't just go like that he
let go slowly and I literally and he
could also hear all sorts of gurgling
going
on so it it was like he pushed a bunch
of crap out of there and then slowly it
just refilled with whatever goodness
that it needed to do and it it felt so
good and my right shoulder is is really
common with gall water um I mean it's
using Mouse and as well at our desks but
it's is different this is like a a right
shoulder pain um that is persistent and
it's it can be worse when you eat fatty
foods because your gallbladder and your
nerves are associated with right
shoulder it will radiate it's called
radiating pain um so when you work on
your gallbladder that if your right
shoulder tightness goes away then you
know it's right shoulder related
and another thing that you can do and
something I actually recommend you to do
is castor oil outside you ever done a
cast oil pack
no okay so go to YouTube type it castor
oil pack look some with something with a
lot of views um and ideally a lot of
comments and a lot of Thumbs Up um but
basically the the cast oil pack is you
get castor oil from the pharmacy um and
uh you get a a cloth that you don't care
about and you know you can get it maybe
the size of you know your your uh soft
part of your abdomen and a couple ribs
higher so it's kind of like a something
you have hanging in your bathroom for
people to dry their hands but little
smaller than that um you soak it in
Castor oil you lay it across your
abdomen then unfortunately you get
something like Saran Wrap or something
just to go around your to to keep keep
it tight around you and then you put on
a garbage t-shirt the shirt that you
don't care about um and because that
Castoro gets in your shirts and your
clothing and and it's just trashed um
and then you just wear it um and I
recommended this often for people uh
with chronic uh pain fibromyalgia
irritable IBS symptoms and what have you
um in your situation I highly recommend
it as well it just it's such a really
really good anti-inflammatory however
works I don't know all the mechanisms
behind itd but it's very very effective
and I was going to ask you like how can
that possibly work is it specifically
Castor castor oil or that's weird yes
specifically castor oil and and uh you
know it's you can do it before bed but
cuddling up next to your partner that's
not really conducive towards wearing a
castor oil P um so maybe just sitting at
your desk during the day while you're
working weird Okay um but also know that
the the the time that your liver and
gallbladder Works according to Chinese
medicine and and maybe other things as
well is very very early in the morning
like 1: to 3 1 to 4: in the morning so
you know castoral pack during the times
of liver activity um would make sense
but again I don't really know what that
means so if you're looking for logical
couldn't explain
it wow wow okay okay I think I have one
more we could continue talking forever
but I'm going to let you go I've got one
more I think applicable question for
people if people have been exposed to
something or they're worried that their
systems overloaded with something um
what are detoxes you could pretty much
recommend people try great I'm glad you
you you Loop this back in because um you
know your exposure to mold is very very
significant people don't understand the
gravity of how terrible mold is I
didn't yeah I just knew it was bad I was
like mold is bad don't live in mold but
I didn't realize like it could be
anywhere and you don't have to see it
and what it could do yeah I mean the
people that are are are exposed
persistently um with low levels of mold
are not performing well they're sucking
down caffeine they're they might be on
anti-depressants they might be on
anxiolytics they might be you know
they're they're on meds of some sort for
a condition they think is something else
but it's actually caused by the mold
okay
so conventional
medicine I respect it I love it for
various things C-section is amazing
broken arms is amazing emergency surgery
is amazing chronic disease they
suck they suck um and they suck because
if you think about what medications do
I'm getting to your point here in a
second they they shut down exactly what
the body is trying to do yeah
anti-histamine they shut down histamine
they don't they don't support histamine
metabolism in any way all the
anti-histamine drug does is prevent the
docking of histamine to the receptor
that's it the histamine is still
circulating in the same amount all
throughout your body badril does nothing
to your histamine levels it just docks
to your histamine receptors so the
histamine can't get there that's all it
does as soon as the badril wears off
hopefully your histamine degrading genes
can process that histamine so The
receptors aren't getting bombarded
anymore but that's all those do so it's
antihistamines anti-depressants
anxiolytics you break up anxiety um
antibiotics everything's against the
body naturopathic medicine functional
medicine is supporting the body it's
nurturing the body okay so there are
moments where you need to tell your body
calm the hell down benad drill is
life-saving you know um you know
inhalers life-saving during the times of
you know epipens life saving awesome um
Nitro same thing um but chronic
persistent issues like mold um I really
want you to evaluate that there's a
there's a book written by my colleague
somewhere in my shelf behind me called
Break the mold I believe yeah um very
very simpa
yes yeah yes yeah great book very
knowledgeable lady um um very practical
of course she was exposed to mold I I
think almost all of us were exposed to
mold at some point unless you live in a
desert um or very very high up in the
mountains which is also a desert
essentially um so detoxification is not
something that you do once a year and
you know oh it's spring I'm going to do
a cleanse all right right well that's
that's great it's nice that you focus on
it but I call detoxing something that or
cleansing is something that you should
be doing every
day and I I call it the ABCs of clean
jeans a is avoid avoidance is the best
way to detox don't get it in the first
place um now granted that is an easy
thing to say but I built my house from
the ground up with many many contractors
no than me um
but my drywall here uh it's a special
type of drywall that uh breaks down from
aldah that's cool we uh yeah our my
flooring in here is cork uh all the
furniture in this office is 100% wood
there's no press board um I have 20
solar panels on my ceiling or or my my
roof but the wire is um out of out of my
way because the magnetism if you
measured the the wire coming from my
solar panel um with a magnetic reader
it's it's insane how high it is um so I
would have had a headache from that and
um so I had that checked out so
detoxification is an everyday thing and
you want to mitigate it as much as
possible we also breathe 11,000 liters
of air every single day so you're you're
breathing if there's microt toxins in
mold in your environment you're
breathing that in and your body has to
do something with it so every inhalation
that you are doing you stimulating your
immune system to fight a foreign object
like mold Spore or that MotoX is
depleting you your essential antioxidant
called
glutathione and so I would say the best
thing to do for Det detoxification
outside of avoidance is
sauna next thing after that I would say
um don't overeat so eat until you're 80%
full
and I was reminded this the other day
when I uh some other kid um got me he's
like Ben Are You full I said yeah 100%
he goes you mean you're not
80% so um but yeah don't eat until
you're you're just stuffed because now
your body has to process that um
carbohydrates go down these really
reactive routes um called the polyol
pathway and the methoxy pathway they're
very very INF fatory um so I think
that's why a lot of people feel better
when they're on the carbohydrate um
reduced diet or keto or or um you know
omad or or carnivore or paleo um you
know Mediterranean I I think just these
types of lifestyles are are very
conducive towards lower carbohydrate
intake which is a a great way to to
detox as well but SAA is very very
important um it doesn't matter if it's
infrared or what have you just you just
sweat so however you want to sweat hot
bath epson salt bath um putting on three
sweatshirts and going for a walk living
in Scottsdale in the summer and going
outside for 10 minutes um you know it
doesn't matter how you sweat if you
don't sweat that's a sign that you have
a a
sympathetic uh sympathetic nervous
system toxicity if you have an inability
to sweat and you just need to keep
pushing through it and working with a
doctor to help clean you out um another
one is to make sure you have bowel
movements every single day at least one
baly to be happening every single day
formed uh in SN every single day and
they should not smell horribly terrible
they should smell you know it's not
going to smell nice but they shouldn't
be offensive and they shouldn't float
and they shouldn't be um you know all
sorts of weird looking things in there
um the other one is glutathione
glutathion though um a lot of people
react to it and um
so and they also talk they talk about
anal cysteine as well so I want to hit
that really quickly but I want to ask
you how do you do with glutathione and
how do you get it IV okay so I had my
blood tested my glutathione is at like
it is depressingly low it's very
deficient and so I was doing vitamin
infusions because my vitamins got all
out of whack and mold too was doing
vitamin infusions and I was doing a
glutathion push at the end and I think
it finally occurred to me that the push
was too much it made me feel way worse
and so I've been considering going in
and doing a a drip just to see but I
just stopped glutathion entirely because
I was doing pushes and it was like oh
I'm reacting to glutathione but my
levels are really deficient so it was
probably maybe an overload of something
I'm not sure but not well and I haven't
tried anything orally because the oral
you know supplements usually have
something that I react to so well Ang
glutathion in your gut is a sulfur
compound and individuals who have gut
issues react to sulfur okay now meat
protein is sulfur too but nowhere near
uh vegetables and
greens um so broccoli cauliflower otter
chokes kale um those types of things are
onions garlic these things are all very
very high in Sulfur and um so that in
Sulfur when you consume it there's
there's a bacteria called hydrogen
sulfide producing bacteria and hydrogen
sulfide producing bacteria are useful
again for motility and blood flow and
circulation that's great but high levels
of hydrogen sulfide will cause
inflammation they'll cause loose stools
diarrhea um and um yeah you'll you'll
actually you can you can tell if someone
is high hydrogen sulfide because you can
smell it on their breath you can smell
in their armpits um e oh I've smell that
not not on me so I don't think I have
that issue but that's the kind
of garlic onion kind of body odor people
can give off body odor yeah body odor
and it can be out of their mouth so
hosis fancy word for bad breath did you
brush your teeth today yeah did you
floss yeah get off my back did you
tongue scrape yeah I scrape my tongue
all right well your gut is a mess um and
you're you're I mean if you think about
your mouth to your butt that's just one
long pipe okay and there's a lot of
twists and turns in that pipe and a lot
of different functions are happening in
that pipe but it's a pipe and when you
breathe bad odors up and out even though
you have very good oral hygiene um that
is a sign that your gut health is is
compromised and I would highly highly
recommend supporting your your liver and
your gallbladder uh in that situation I
really want you supporting your your
gallbladder but we need to to do it in a
way that's that's uh you know conducive
towards where you are right now Castor
packs is one way and that organ organ
massage is going to be really really
important for you um and uh I think and
then eating lower fatty foods but go
back to your your your
glutathione
um glutathione the halflife halflife is
is the term for how long a compound is
active in your body before it becomes
damaged or or has to be recycled gluto
halflife is 12 minutes histamine is 1
minute oh it should be 1 minute it
should be 12 minutes so if someone had
an anaphylactic reaction let's say
shrimp or peanut butter or
peanuts they they have an asthma attack
their throat swells they can't breathe
you know they take the Ben andrill or
EpiPen or whatever they do and um
they're inhaler and then they feel fine
okay if you took their blood histamine
levels 2 minutes later it' probably look
normal
so histamine comes off super fast and
the body breaks it down super fast it
should not always but so measuring blood
histamine levels in people is is not
very
useful um measuring urinary histamine
levels can be more
useful um because urinary histamine can
show histamine production through the
microbiome um oh cool which I think is
more interesting but you can also absorb
histamine from the gut into your blood
as well um but urinary isine is probably
more effective now back to
glutathione um glutathione side effects
are very very real and I have a lot of
health professionals on my butt about
this because they love their glutathion
they love their gluty pushes and IVs um
and they say patients do very very well
from it um so I don't like you on the
internet talking about how bad
glutathione is I said look I love
glutathione I offer
glutathione I take glutathione but but I
also respect it and I know that there's
a fine line between
benefit and problem so glutathion here's
my recommendation take low amounts
frequently pushes generally speaking if
you feel great once if you go in again
the likelihood you feeling great from
the second or third push that you get
from the IV very very low because you're
depleting your mum stores you're you're
depleting your
um uh well you're not only depleting but
you're you're raising the glutathione
levels up so much and your body makes
glutathione from from multiple things
glutamate Glycine and
cysteine so if if you're receiving
glutathione from an IV then your body is
going to be utilizing that glycine
glutamate and cysteine in other ways
right because it doesn't need to make
glutathion anymore so now it's going to
divert those three compounds somewhere
else well glutamate is very excitatory
yeah right so you're going to get
headaches you're going to get irritable
and then the cysteine is going to
convert to cysteine which is very
pro-inflammatory and it's also going to
make sulfites so now you're going have
breathing difficulties red rashes on
your body you're going to have diarrhea
loose stools um and uh that's no fun um
and glycine can can increase anxiety as
well so and and what's going to happen
is the doctor going to say oh these are
just um detox reactions no no they're
not they're not detox reactions at all
they're they are um the result of you
getting too much glutathione and there's
research studies that Show Low
glutathione levels increase glutamate
excit toxicity in your brain so you get
irritable and headaches and so on the
perfect amount of glutathione you don't
have this glutamate cytotoxicity high
levels of glutathion you also have
glutamate oyot toxic ah okay so it's
like the Three Bears you got to find
that goldilock spot with glutathione and
so and and the compound of glutathione
that you get is important so there's
reduced glutathione and there's s acetal
glutathione you want s acetal
glutathione um so my company used
reduced glutathione for for years
because that was really the only
glutathione that was available and
reduced glutathione means that's the
glutathione that is ready to be used by
your body and it's it's good it's it's
ready to go after glutathion does its
job it becomes what's called oxidized or
damaged and damaged glutathione will
give you side effects too so if you have
a reduced ability to recycle your your
glutathion back from uh so you you take
the glutathion push here's another
reason that doesn't work very well you
take the glutathione you use the
glutathion for its beneficial outcomes
to get the beneficial outcome but now
you have the damage glutathion and it's
is building up now you have more damaged
glutathione in your body than you do
good glutathione you do a lab test the
Lab Test shows oh your glutathione
levels are higher that's good no
glutathione test on the market today
shows you with credibility how much
oxidized or damaged glutathione you have
to uh free and and and good glutathione
levels none it's not possible because
the second you draw the blood out of the
human body it's oxidized
M it's going to be damaged it's exposed
to air it's
damaged so getting glutathion blood
tests in my opinion even if you get red
blood cell glutathione is not that
useful in terms of identifying if you
have good or damaged glutathione levels
in your body so and vitam vitamin B2 I.E
riboflavin is is the compound that helps
your body recycle damaged into good and
I cannot tell you how many people have
low levels of of riboflavin a
lot that was one thing that I had well
vitamin B12 anyway were extremely
high uh your B12 yeah extremely high
like weirdly High I think and then fate
after being in that moldy house very
very low I started injecting though
folate and so my levels are better I
think that helped me actually I think I
could physically feel that oh yeah um
but it was weird to me that B12 was so
high and F it was so low well that's a
whole another ball ball wax um they've
done research studies on pregnant women
where they say if a pregnant woman has
high B12 or high F Aid levels their her
risk of having a child with autism uh is
significant and the as that's the end up
of the research and I say well is it
because they're supplementing or is it
because their biochemical pathways are
blocked from being able to utilize that
B12 and and folate and also the bacteria
in your digestive system produce B12 and
folate that show up on your your lab
result right so um your bacteria in your
gut can produce B12 it's not it's not
human it you can't use it
physiologically it's not the right type
of B12 but it can show up in your labs
and affect your results in fact that's
actually one of the ways to identify
sibo from a high high B12 level really
okay
and would that show up along with low
folate or is it generally high and high
it can and it's it's also it's called it
can be potentially called uh methyl
trapping um because if you look on your
strategy report we have the methylation
pathway you have one circle on your left
this is the Fate pathway then you have
the methylation cycle and so this is
your fate this is your B12 and where
they
intersect is an area where B12 and fate
are used at the same time if you're low
and glutathione right here here where
they intersect you can't use either of
them and mold prevents the utilization
of that pathway from working because at
this
intersection even if you have sufficient
full8 and b12 levels in the presence of
logo to it won't spin it just
stops so um that's why detoxing and I
mentioned glutathion being super super
important that's also why I dedicated
more time to this conversation because I
don't want everybody running out and
taking gluthione and getting headaches
and irrit and and uh you know loose
toools from it and saying oh it's just a
detox
reaction use less and whatever suggested
use says on the bottle it just means
suggested use in order to Define what
the supplement facts serving size is so
if if a a liposomal glutathione says
suggested use one teaspoon a day that
one teaspoon provides what's in the
supplement fax panel which is um usually
you know anywhere from 100 to 500
milligrams of glutathione and again I
don't want you using reduced glutathione
in a liposome I want you using S acetal
glutathione and a liposome because the S
acetyl is very very stable it's going to
keep it reduced until it gets in your
digestive system and that esle will get
cut off and you can use the the
glutathione again and my own company
used uh reduced gluon for years and now
um and and our as you'll see our one
liposomal glutathione is esal there's
other two that we're we're transitioning
out of but I do think some of the side
effects that people get from when
they're supplementing with glutathion is
because they're already getting it
oxidized
oh like fish oil most fish oil on the
market too just fish oil in a
capsule only take fish oil capsules do
not take fish oil in a liquid because as
soon as you open that top and you have a
jar of and I don't care if it tastes
like strawberry yogurt or whatever P
colada you know you see all these fish
oils out there nowadays and gummies
gummies are horrible for fish oil as
well because they're getting oxidized
only inside of a capsule and they should
be uh certified by this organization
called iOS which is like International
fish oil something or other and um so
some of these certifications like
dolphin safe can be nonsense um but the
ifos certification they t for rancidity
mercury levels uh stability and all that
so you want your official iOS
certified cool well Ben I think I'm
going to let you go uh it's been that
was really informative it's crazy like I
did so much research on diet and um I
have I didn't finish a University degree
but I spent uh a number of years taking
biomedical science degree and reading
studies and trying to figure this out
and I didn't realize how much my envir
enironment played a role so I've been
doing like you were talking about how
your house is built and things and my
house isn't built like that but the next
house maybe we'll use sire wall or
something but I've been doing like
non-toxic furniture and I'm worried
about like what the leather's been dyed
with when it comes into the house and
it's just like it's full-time job so I
appreciate you coming in yeah it is it's
it's overwhelming and and uh another
thing I want to say is is is clean is
the absence of smell yeah it's not the
presence of a
fragrance so Dyer scented dryer sheets
or scented uh laundry detergent or
scented soap for washing your dishes or
scented anything is is actually putting
a burden on your body because a lot of
these scents are full of phalates and
they get right to your brain and they
stay there um and so and your body has
to process all these toxic aldhy so
clean is the absence of smell it's not
the presence of any smell whether it's
good or not
fze um you know it's horrible stuff um a
lot of people get triggered from that
wet swifters too yeah swiffers swiffers
yeah swiffers swiffers yep and they they
uh good name um they uh increase Mass
cell um release any any fragrances
release massel so it's interesting when
my oldest son would put on a cologne I
just i' first he would do it in my in
our home and I told him I don't want
that in our house you wear it if you
want that colog you you put it onself in
your own car not not here and then
sometimes he would just do it anyway and
i' just turn into a rage monster yeah
and um and I I actually think I turned
into rage monster once well partially
because he disrespected the rules of the
house secondly because he uh the
the compound released mass cells and too
much hist to me will increase
irritability yeah that's my my husband
and I got married and he's got similar
like some similar sensitivities and
things he was using like Hairspray and
clone and I was like you're in for a
surprise with me that's got to go here's
some hair mud this is your new hair
product there's no s he's like oh
Michaela like yeah well it's the
fragrances or
me yeah my After Shave is made by my
wife it's it's uh Birch buds from a
birch Tre
soaked in
vodka um like a tincture like herbal
tincture and then we filter the the
stuff after into a little spray bottle
and it's I've been using that for 15
years and just after I shave I just
spray this Birch Bud vodka stuff on my
face she loves it the smell is very very
subtle and it's it's just gone and um
it's natural and it dries the skin it's
great for your skin and
so I recommend Birch butd after
sh the the only thing that Jordan has
left he comes out of the bathroom
sometimes like what did you do did you
use a soap like what's that spell and it
says After Shave like okay that's got to
go and after shaves are turning him
into more estrogen on the tissues the TA
and the other properties so just tell
them that um so but you know it's even
just getting vodka and putting vodka in
a spray bottle
I could tolerate that yeah yeah yeah
okay
well um do you have websites you could
lead people to for people to find out
more about the supplements and what you
do yeah um so we we did talk about sauna
so um if you go to seeking health.com
like looking so seeking
health.com and then there's in the learn
there's a category called learn you can
click the how-to sauna there's a blurb
in there how to sa it because if you
sauna incorrectly you will get worse and
I'm just going to quickly say you have
to sauna properly and it's not a
marathon if you walk into a sauna and
you feel terrible get out don't don't
force yourself to stay in a sauna the
first time I got in a sauna I could only
literally stay in there for about 30 to
60 seconds and I felt terrible I did a
lot of Roundup uh growing up as a kid
and um second I got in that sauna it
just came from my tissues and into my
blood and into my brain and I I felt
awful um so don't ever ever think you
need to be manly and or womanly or
whatever you want to call it in a in a
sauna second you feel like you're done
you're done um so that's important so
seeing health.com is the supplements and
education is we becoming a health
company strategy and our genetic report
is on there um that's what Michaela ran
and then the history report isn't out
yet but it's interesting and it's it's
also it's very interesting and I I loved
how you ended um and saying that you
know how much you respect the
environment playing a role in your
health because when you look at your
Hine report you know at some point
you're going to see that histamine
genetics are not that significant um in
your
life I'll say that report is made by me
and my team and we could be incorrect in
some of our things that we're reporting
they actually may be more significant
than that we're saying um so but time
will only tell um Instagram I'm on but
I'm also shadowban so you know but you
can find me at drb Lynch and uh I think
those are the two spots uh primarily I'm
starting to get back on Twitter
SLX um but I I'm not really much of a
Twitter user that's a very interesting
environment yeah it it's definitely
interesting okay well thank you very
much for talking to me yeah keep me
updated how you're improving and and um
focus on your uh phase of eating and
chewing and Gast oil pack and getting
that organ
[Music]
massage